bien pues ahora que tenemos conceptos
básicos de operaciones y su orden
tratemos de abordar un problema un poco
más bestial
así que por aquí tenemos todo tipo de
paréntesis y números al aire pero
cualquier tipo de problema con
operaciones
simplemente se aborda tomando una
profunda respiración y recordando lo
primero que sería que se empieza a
realizar con los paréntesis primero
luego vamos hacia los exponentes y no te
preocupes ya sabes cuáles son los
exponentes en este caso es porque no hay
luego realizas la multiplicación y
división que están como al mismo nivel
de orden de operación y luego vienen las
sumas y las restas donde estas iniciales
forman un p de ese ere y si a ti te
recuerdan dichas iniciales el orden pues
podrás utilizarlo entonces vamos a
comenzar y bien no olvides que la
multiplicación y la división están a un
mismo nivel de orden de operación al
igual que la suma y la resta
y bueno por aquí tenemos dos paréntesis
uno dentro del otro el amarillo está
dentro del de color rosa entonces este
cómo se abordaría bien pues vamos a
empezar de adentro hacia afuera así que
comencemos resolviendo lo que está
dentro de nuestro paréntesis de color
amarillo es simplemente una resta
entonces 5 menos 2 nos da 3 y ahora
vamos a poner lo que se encuentra afuera
de nuestros paréntesis tenemos que aquí
sería 7 más 3 por 3 que fue el resultado
que nos dio de nuestros países amarillos
y lo volvemos a cerrar con sus
respectivos paréntesis y vemos que del
lado derecho estamos dividiendo entre 4
por 2 perdón ese no era simplemente
quiero copiar y pegar esta parte para
acá abajo y de plano estoy teniendo un
poco de problemas técnicos pero bueno
simplemente lo voy a reescribir para no
tardar demasiado entonces tenemos que
estaría entre 4 que también está
multiplicado su vez por 2 y de nuestro
lado izquierdo tenemos que sí
por dos más nuestros términos que están
dentro del paréntesis rosa y bien
siguiendo otra vez el orden de
operaciones pues volvemos a tener que
resolver la parte interior de nuestro
paréntesis por aquí vemos que tenemos
una suma y una multiplicación entonces
una vez más volteando a ver nuestro
orden tendremos que realizar primero
nuestra multiplicación de tres por tres
y luego ese resultado sumarse lo a 7
entonces tenemos que 3 por 3 es igual a
9 simplemente estuve respetando nuestro
orden de operaciones entonces si te das
cuenta la multiplicación sea lo que
sigue antes de realizar la suma entonces
ahora sí 3 por 3 nos da 9 más 7 esto
vendría siendo 16 entonces lo voy a
escribir primero paso por paso para que
no nos vayamos a perder entonces vamos a
poner 7 más 9 que fue lo de nuestra
multiplicación y de nuestro lado
izquierdo una vez más estas 7 por 2
lo que queda dentro de nuestro
paréntesis entre 4 por 2 y bueno ahora
que ya nos queda algo más sencillo si
tratamos de seguir una vez más el orden
de operación seguirá lo del paréntesis
nada más nos queda una suma la cual nos
arroja un resultado de 16 y entonces
ahora si se fueron los paréntesis
tenemos 7 por 2 más 16 entre 4 por 2 y
bueno cada paso que realices es
importante que vayas volteando a ver
cómo es el orden de operación entonces
tenemos paréntesis ahora ya no tenemos
no tenemos exponentes entonces ahora que
sigue la multiplicación que tenemos una
de este lado y otra de este otro lado y
la división entonces vamos a ver cómo
sería resolverlo antes que realizar la
suma pues tendríamos que resolver
nuestras principales operaciones
entonces 7 por 2 es 14
+ 16 que es el término que se queda
hasta el último y bien ahora te
preguntarás cuál resuelvo primero la
división o la multiplicación y bueno en
el vídeo anterior te dije que para este
tipo de casos cuando teníamos
operaciones que iban como a un mismo
nivel de orden simplemente lo que
hacemos es resolverlas como de izquierda
a derecha entonces aquí sería resolver
16 entre 4 nos da 4 y luego ese
resultado lo multiplicamos por 2
entonces 16 entre 4 es 4 por 2 por
nuestro 2 y ahora si tenemos que 4 por 2
nos va a dar 8 y finalmente se puede
resolver dicha suma entonces voy a
anotar nuestro resultado de nuestro
rectángulo que ahora puse en color
morado y sería 14 + 8 nuestro resultado
final
14 8 simplemente resuelves la suma y
este resultado nos queda 22 y listo
ahora sí lo hemos acabado